all right a couple other quick stories
that I will not spend a ton of time on
right now many of you wrote to me and
said David Trump advisor Stephen Bannon
has been sentenced he got four months in
jail and that is true but he's not going
to serve a day of it at least not for
now because of an immediate appeal so
the update on that you might recall that
Trump adviser Steve Bannon was
subpoenaed by the January 6 committee he
ignored the subpoena he was um charged
with contempt of congress he was found
guilty he has now been sentenced indeed
as the Associated Press reports Bannon
was sentenced to four months for defying
the January 6th subpoena uh District
Carl District Judge Carl Nichols however
allows Bannon to stay free pending
appeal a potentially lengthy process and
also imposed a fine of sixty five
hundred dollars as part of the sentence
pretty strict huh 6 500 bucks Bannon was
convicted in July on two counts of
contempt of congress one for refusing to
sit for a deposition the other for
refusing to provide documents uh Nichols
handed down the sentence after saying
the law is clear contempt of congress is
subject to a mandatory minimum of a
month Behind Bars bannon's lawyers said
you could give him probation prosecutors
said give him six months and my view
said the judge Mr Bannon has not taken
responsibility for his actions you think
others must be deterred from committing
similar crimes prosecutors argued Bannon
deserves the longer sentence because he
pursued a bad faith strategy
and his public statements disparaging
the committee itself made it clear that
his goal was to undermine their effort
to figure out what happened on January
6th he chose to hide behind fabricated
claims of executive privilege and advice
of counsel to thumb his known at his
thumb is nose at Congress your honor the
defendant is not above the law and that
is exactly what makes this case
important it must be made clear to the
public to the citizens that no one is
above the law
um so sentenced if he ultimately serves
the four months because now there will
be a very lengthy appeals process and
who knows if he will
is four months even a serious deterrent
and what I mean by that is
hard of defying these subpoenas to the 1
6 committee
is about showing loyalty to the cult
leader showing loyalty to the cult to
Trump I'm gonna stay true
I'm going to ignore the subpoena
if four months is all that is at the
worst case waiting for you on the other
end of it it doesn't seem like a
particularly strong deterrent from
continuing to show your loyalty to the
cult now again I have to mention this
because of the comments I'm seeing about
oh bannon's going to get raped in prison
he'll learn real quick first of all
the place Bannon is likely to go would
be like a lower Security Federal
facility the type of place that Michael
Cohen went to
there's not a lot of prison rape
happening there but more importantly
I've said this before and I want to say
it again
when people talk about oh you know even
if they only get four months it's going
to be worse because they're going to get
raped in prison
that is a disaster the fact that our
prison system is so ineffective at
keeping prisoners safe that sometimes
their sexual assault shouldn't be
something that we relish and say well
you can count on the punishment being a
little worse guys it's disgusting okay
and I don't care if the sentenced
individual is a Democrat or Republican a
progressive a conservative or whatever
the fact that sometimes people are
sexually assaulted in prison is just a
reminder of how a poorly functioning our
prison system is so let's not stoop to
that level Bannon is appealing let's see
what if anything he ultimately serves
the David packman shows longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers I've been been using blinkist
for years to supplement the books I read
I love reading I read all the time but
there's even more books I don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
Blink is connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users I have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com
davidpackman
the link is down below